oh [__] the church is brought to you by
on it.com
on it has the best supplements out there
i've been messing around with them for
the last five six seven years i know the
president aubry and the development guy
personally and i love what they do
uh they have a tremendous alpha brain
and new mood and shroom tech and the
alpha brain which is their flagship
if you're not happy with it you got 100
money-back guarantee who the [__] does
this in this day and age 100
100 money-back guarantee don't even want
the pills back take the pills and snort
them and go shoot yourself whatever the
[__] you do
do me a favor go to honor look at their
fine line of supplements
from their acai
milkshake to the to the cacao hemp force
protein
i mean this is a a tremendous company
they got great steel bats they've got
kettlebells they've got apparel they've
got blenders but do me a favor go to
honor.com right now
and if you see something you like press
in church boom and i got your 10 off
delivered right to your house who's
better than uncle joey number two listen
the summer's coming your asshole's gonna
sweat
it happens you know what i'm saying not
that you're special not that you're a
stinky dude you're [__] switch you're
on match.com you got [__] happening okay
you're hanging out with christian
minglers
you got [__] uh what do you call
those other people uh farmers daughters
listen you want a sling dick it's the
summertime it's tough to sling dick when
your balls smell like [__] ass
and they they're mixed you ever scratch
your balls in the afternoon and you can
smell your [__] and your ballsack you
don't need that no more you know why
because the days are back [__]
hellotushy.com that's the answer to your
problems right there you can't get dates
scratch your ass after a shower if you
[__] stinks after a shower maybe
that's why you don't get dates
everything's fine until a girl blows
your flute then she takes away for that
dungeon of death and that's it they
don't want to call they don't want to do
nothing no more then you wonder why
hellotushy.com is the answer to all your
problems right there it's water that
sprinkles into your muffin you could sit
there for two [__] years i don't give
a [__] you could sit there until the
california drought comes back but listen
i'll tell you about it more all right
right now go to hellotushy.com
get yourself a portable bidet it's it
it's going to change your life [__]
therapy [__] adderall
go to hellotushy.com right now
press in church bam get 10 off again
60 day 90 day guarantee whatever the
[__] there's no guarantees this thing
ain't breaking if it could take my
[__] 300 pound ass it'll take you a
little skinny chicken [__] bone ass
all right
hellotushy.com on it.com give me some
love hit it lee
[Music]
bam [__]
it's wednesday thursday whatever the
[__] it don't matter you're slinging
dick rain snow sleet
[__] hurricanes
the church of what's happening now baby
kick that mule league
every time i see dean delray i think of
this song
so this is why whatever dean's on this
song is not whether you like it or not
this is as good as it gets into those
guitars
[Music]
lights out lights out here we go here we
go
oh man dean's getting all rushed up
without the reefer tonight he's so low
he went back to n a he can't smoke a
bomb
he's on the motorcycle what the [__]
i wouldn't get on a motorcycle at night
unless i was smoking reef
that's the only way i could go down that
[__] laurel canyons with 92 bongits
and a [__] take this put this put sam
lazaro in your jacket
that's your lucky [__] charm for me
i'll take it man greetings to the church
dean del rey my little nephew lisa we're
here with queer
it's a whole new [__] week thank you
for enjoying steve rena's easy other day
we had a good time in studio but now we
got my main man the music
extraordinaire the comic of [__]
the future mr dean del rey
fresh from denver in his first [__]
cd
vinyl whatever the [__] you wanted yeah
vinyl record on pong load records man
what perfect name right and taped in
denver were the crowds good people oh
man
the
wednesday over 120 30 people which i
thought you know wednesday then thursday
like 160 then friday and saturday full
both shows uh completely full then a
sunday uh like 130 or so it's like it
was awesome man it's the rockies it's
not the broncos you don't want to
[__] do a sunday there on broncos oh
no it's a slow death yeah yeah right
people who do show up to the [__]
show or people who came from the bronco
game
and if you suck they'll throw a [__]
helmet at you they [__] fired up
those people so i'm happy i'm happy it
went well dean a snowstorm full-blown
snowstorm breaks out so we get there and
it's like you know 70 and we're like
beautiful and then we wake up and it's
just a [__] a foot of snow just crazy
as that it was crazy it was freezing out
how crazy is that that it goes from zero
to 60 and you can't explain it to people
yeah like you just can't i saw one time
february
second of 1990 i got to the bctc the
halfway house yeah okay i get out at one
o'clock in the afternoon
me and my wife at the time
go to eat at this cajun place that was a
house and it was downstairs and upstairs
in a yard lucille's yeah cajun place see
if it's still there in boulder lucille's
oh my god they used to have a red
snapper
with two eggs sunny side up and benays
and [__] oh man are you [__] kidding
me what's it in boulder boulder well
i'll never forget that i went in there
about one o'clock we had the two eggs
the [__] uh benates it's still there
since 1980 who the [__] do you think
you're dealing with wow
so we go in there and we get the let's
see whatever see what the breakfast
options i was looking at the location uh
21 24 14th street it's like a yellow
house yeah it is the house yeah holy
[__] what about the menu see what they
got for breakfast okay because they're
only open for breakfast and lunch
they're one of those type of places i
like those places yeah at that time
that's when they're telling you do you
want breakfast yeah okay they have a
organic egg scramble i don't think you
got that
it has tofu and stuff uh has eggs
ponchoranian with uh trout
it has blackened salmon there you go egg
sardu which is creamed spinach and
shrimp actually looks good no no they
don't [__] around a new orleans praline
waffle with pecan batter oh [__] eggs
benedict
eggs jennifer which is
has spinach and avocado and tomato
eggs new orleans has fried eggplant and
creole sauce oh that sounds good
pan perdue is nearly in style french
toast
and then they have rice pudding a cheese
omelet they have they have a big menu
yeah yeah well when i was going there
they had like a red snapper a darkened
red snapper with two eggs potatoes yeah
man that's toast sounds like they
replace that with salmon yeah salmon
freshly squeezed orange juice i mean i
go in there i eat this big [__] meal
i don't get high i'm in the halfway
house it's my first day out
you know it's like whenever you make a
change your body is all worked up for
that change yep and her and i went back
to the house and we probably fell asleep
like a four during the afternoon maybe
and next thing you know she was waking
me up now when she picked me up that
that friday afternoon when i got out
it was 65 yeah beautiful
sun was out birds were chirping not a
cloud in the [__] sky i go in at 4
30. now i had a dog then i had hercules
then yeah so i went to walk him and it
was still beautiful
i went in fell asleep
she woke me up with two that the water
had broken i go outside there's a foot
of [__] snow [__] and a full-on
blizzard and you're like okay it's
february yeah but when you see that [__]
in april and may it was nuts it's nuts
and then you see it in september yeah
colorado always lets you know who's boss
in september yeah september like 15th
they'll dump a foot of snow on you
you're like jesus christ and then it'll
be gone in a day and a half it was gone
gone gone the day it was like it didn't
even happen no it's like [__] nothing
it was so weird it was like beautiful
like i was there two weeks before with
marin so you know 80
wearing a t-shirt the whole time didn't
bring anything in my bag so this time i
go yeah same thing you know what i mean
uh it's going to be blazing uh i just
want to bring my podcast gear and a
couple shirts i don't give a [__] and
man i step out from the friday night
show and it's like this
death wind blowing down that [__]
15th street there and just snow just shh
hitting me i was like oh what the [__]
and it go it pumped all day and night
did you go to that place and eat
with the green family sam's yeah yeah
but i got a new spot there now where i
go up the street to this joint called
they got five of them in denver snooze
and it's like um it's a breakfast joint
but they have this homemade chicken
sausage that i i gotta have every day
they got one in san diego too and then
they have a quinoa oatmeal that's just
[__] can you believe what i'm
listening yeah
can you believe the insult he just
green chili for we quinoa [__]
oatmeal i was doing i was doing sam's at
night i you know getting sloppy at night
i go in there i can do all three dean
this is like this might be your last
appearance for like a year now you're
gonna be probably [__] old i'll tell
you what though it is good well i'm in
denver dog there's only that that's it i
only see sam's yeah because i know i'll
never get that again anywhere yeah even
though the burgers with the green chili
on them and the swiss cheese with the
peppers
they don't [__] around they got that
back bar there they got the back bar
they got milkshakes i got the shirt i
don't even need any of that stuff i get
the two eggs yeah with bacon and a thing
of [__] green chili my main thing
there is the green chili i got the steak
and eggs that one you told me to get you
know what i mean yeah i get the steak
and eggs i go late night there every
night after the show i go there this
isn't food related but i saw a video you
did at uh red rocks oh yeah and i've
never been to denver we've talked
briefly about red rocks on the podcast
before oh yeah let's talk legitimately
in it's like the grand canyon that's
right i love driving through that kind
of like i just love but it's like it's
in that it just looks so cool it's my
dream to play there right so chappelle's
doing it this summer they did oddball
there last year but you know as a kid
and you know this joey
they you know u2 shoots this infamous
concert there and as a kid i was like
wow did they build that place like what
the [__] is that just those two uh stone
walls and then the amphitheater and it's
all wood seats and the view of denver
downtown so we go out there immediately
once the snow hits and uh to see it you
know all snowed up and it's open all the
time with no concert for just hiking
around which is so cool you can hike
this whole [__] place you can get on
the stage and sing bloody sunday's
bloody sunday you know sunday bloody son
that's the famous was it security at
least no there's no it's just a like a
state park
and they got a a visitors center i went
in the visitor center it's so [__]
cool we learned so much about this place
it opened in 1906 it was called like
garden of the gods and it had no no
sound system back then it was
acoustically perfect where people could
play and they would hear it and
eventually over the years it got bigger
and bigger you know to turn it into a
full concert venue the beatles played
there in 1964.
i took a picture of the photo the fans
are out there boulder loves the beatles
they played there on their first run man
insane and here's a crazy thing
in like the 70s if you look it up lee
wikipedia
uh
like early 70s uh jethro toll played
there
and like a thousand people showed up
with no tickets and stormed the joint
there was like a mini riot and they
banned rock there for years
like years man
and then this guy the denver promoter
like
71 71 worked it to where rock could be
there in like 80 or something i don't
know but u2 is one of the first ones to
go there and play you know but [__]
hendricks played there so there's a
secret tunnel
uh from the stage underneath that goes
up to the sound board and i guess every
rock star signed the tunnel and there's
like hendrix signatures beetles doors
all that stuff like signatures on this
wall
i didn't know it went back that far
that's really interesting i couldn't
believe it either man i thought it
opened like in the 80s that's how
[__] dumb i am i did too though
because i didn't know about that in the
80s no i thought it opened up with
youtube me too i thought they built this
yeah
i went there a few times very
interesting you know
great place to trip and see a concert i
mean when you go there you really
understand the concept of having for
your friends
and taking mushrooms or ass that's what
you're into totally and just walking
around there and seeing the concert and
seeing the sunset
and all that it's [__] really short
really sharp it really is it's my
favorite place in america
you know i only went there like three
times
but uh
i should have gone wrong i was into
different [__] things can you imagine
if like five of us did it like say like
a a rogan me
you
uh a marin and a burr or something you
know and and like henchka for somebody
you know like like this like like
two-hour crazy show man you know it'd be
great i'm excited i'm excited to see
what chappelle does there oh yeah i
didn't know that chapel was there yeah
man it sold out in like five minutes
is it the show with john mayer or no no
it's him yeah it's him because yeah so
but yeah he's had with me what is he
doing do you know what that show is he
just does comedy and uh you know and
then john mayer plays you know it's cool
that's a different concept that's like
70s you know like remember all the
comics i opened for allison chains this
summer it's like old school back then
comics opened for bands
you know carl and healing for everybody
it's funny i never saw a comedian open
for all those concerts i went to i would
have remembered i never saw a comic open
it was it was all those early 70s is
when they did it okay i started going to
concerts me too because i never saw it
either but bobcat
opened for nirvana for a whole [__]
tour on their big tour no yeah i got the
shirt man uh and if you talk to bobcat
he tells crazy stories like some were
good and some were horrible you know
it's just him out there
back in the bobcat days you know look at
that
going crazy and open for nirvana on the
big tour they did the cow palace in san
fran
oh man what's that seat
uh 15 000. oh my god yeah
i just [__] my pants thinking about it
hopefully enough for a band that's a
different animal oh it's so hard opening
up for a a you know a comedy show is one
thing yeah but for a [__] concert you
gotta bring it jack oh i did it man and
people look at you like why is that
rhodey up there talking it's crazy it's
a different feel
and when it goes bad
like he said it goes bad and you got
tick-tock that's when you know
time is [__] crazy oh you know what
time goes long for me at the store or
original room
it seems like the set's never gonna end
really that's why i get off as soon as i
get the light at the store i don't [__]
around like i'm happy to get the [__]
out of there you feel like that right
yeah it's crazy
there's some rooms that that just make
me uh
like how long am i up here yeah yeah
uh where was i recently where it's time
is forever yeah it's for [__] ever
you're like jesus christ like the first
night levity in oxnard the guy made a
mistake he gave me a light an hour yeah
so at the end our i'm like i'm out of
[__] material here
i didn't know it but i knew it i'm like
i'm dead yeah and finally gives me a
light and i close up and i get off stage
and they're like you did an hour 20 and
i'm like no i didn't they're like yeah
you did the guy gave me the letter an
hour i'm like jesus [__] christ
trying to kill me up here that's the
worst because if you give me a light at
40 at least i know the light by the way
for people at home listening
there's a light that the sound board
gives you let you know how much time you
got left
you know most comics want to do an hour
so they got a light at 50 letting them
know they have a 10 minutes to wrap it
up you know so
i usually like a light at 40 so i could
take 20 to wrap it up because you're
usually in the middle of a [__]
segment
five to get out of that and then a 15
minute closing you're the [__] out of
there yep
but when they stretch that they're not
paying attention and you know
something's not right on stage you're
like something's not right on [__]
state yeah this time is going a little
different here then you know it you feel
it why don't you guys have a clock on
the stage like it seems it seems like
i've never seen a comic really get off
like would you if that in that scenario
if it hit an hour 30 and still no light
would have just been like good night and
you'd be like i know i didn't i had no
idea i'm watching the waitresses okay
gotcha i'm watching the waitresses
coming back and giving change if i see
the waitress is giving change i'm in the
vicinity to get the [__] off right okay
that makes sense because they don't want
them sitting there if they can't drink
yep
check drops happen that's why they ask
you how much time you're doing that's
why when a comic goes into a club
and tells the soundboard gamer to do an
hour
there's two hours and 30 minutes the
club is furious we don't care if you do
two hours and 30 minutes but let us know
because then the people sit there
for an hour with no drinks because now
they got to reopen the [__] credit
card yeah
gosh that's why clubs get mad when
certain people come in and do five hours
or three hours or two hours
because it throws that clientele off
yeah so the timing you know i can't
imagine it and the bigger the theater
the bigger your response to laughter
back to your punch line yep so for
people at home if you go see a comic in
a theater and you go see a comedian at a
comedy club and you go wow it was two
different shows because
that time
there's 2 200 seats in comparison to 260
seats and there's all this [__] air
to cover and believe it or not the
laughter is a little slower yeah like if
if it's laughter that goes from
beginning to back
you have to count three before you hit
him with the second joke
it's a very interesting concept first
five times you do theaters you're in
limbo yeah you really are in limbo until
you pick that
whole thing up and i think the first
person who spoke about it was i think
kennison
spoke about it on an interview or
something that's when i thought about
well that's right your timing is
different
in theaters it's a really interesting
concept who gives a [__] you people at
home going joey i'm a plumber
i give a [__] about timing in an
auditorium it's true though i mean it's
just timing in life you know what i mean
like learn learn timing on any kind of
thing i remember when i was doing the
first one i was going to do with russell
peters was like 10 000. and i called
maron in the parking lot at the store
you know i was like [__] man tomorrow
didn't so i called him up hey man i'm
doing like that 10 000 cedar ma and i
remember he's like oh you got this man
he goes but remember one thing
go slow
and i was like go slow and he goes yeah
when you think the laughs are done
they're not even they're not even close
no that's why yeah and so you're
stepping on your own material yeah i'm
so glad he told me because what happens
is the first three or four worlds are
the laughs you hear
but they're not even you know it's not
even close yet to being done
it's a
it's a journey and a half
and you you know your your milestones
are your cds or your
specials or whatever nobody ever gave me
a special
so for a guy like me you gotta start at
cds whether you're [__]
the first cdi tapers at the three of
clubs yeah yeah on a tuesday night
that's a great 60 people
then the second one i taped was with
this guy that died god bless his soul
good comic
he would do him at the lab factory and
they give you thirty three dollars a
minute
thirty three dollars a minute yeah so
let's say you did two hours yeah but
they kept an hour it was thirty three
dollars a minute wow that's what you
they pay you that in like 500 bucks
yeah they give you
50 cds when the cd came out and the rest
of them you had to buy from them wow i
took the 50 i never bought a dime from
them again they kept [__] me why
aren't you going to buy more [__] you
you sell them
so now when you go to the truck stops
they still have them at truck stops all
over texas louisiana
the midwest what was it called
i [__] forget
that i wish it was called that
and you know he took pictures and [__]
he never okayed him with me yeah you
know it's like one day i get this thing
in the mail it's my finished cd
i was pissed i'm like you never gave me
an okay like
he took the pictures and he disappeared
wow i thought he's gonna call back and
go those pictures were ridiculous no all
of a sudden it's a picture of me with
two chicks
i'm gonna cover on the [__] blue
album that's what it's called
the blue out really
wow how many cds you got out
the blue album
live from the three of spades three of
spades
three guns yeah yeah clubs
um
he's either you or the priest
yep [__] with asthma yep savage dad
six man that's [__] dope i'm like i'm
at the point of uh we sold our soul for
rock and roll it's a six thousand oh wow
right it's a six thousand yep yep yep
what was zeppelin six thousand uh
presents
is the presence let's see you go
zeppelin one two three
then you got the four the house of the
holy men houses of the holy yeah
presents
wow those are all good and then in
through the outdoor and then coda
no you have physical graffiti in there
too oh yeah [__] i almost forgot it
physical groovy six oh six there you go
yeah i forgot about that one completely
yeah
you know we you and i have a weird taste
for music
you're more obscure but your
fundamentals
and my fundamentals of music are pretty
similar
so we have something to work with i have
friends that they're fundamentals of
music
and my fundamentals of music are
completely
uh different
and i never [__] thought about it i
never thought about it all you and i
have had countless conversations about
music
and you're out of town
and a few weeks ago i'm in my
office and i go jesus christ
not only there's a smell in here
but it's dirty like it's dirty yeah so i
unplugged the speakers
the the headphones and i put on i was
scrolling like what can i play that i
haven't played in a long time
and i go you know what let me put on
power range which was always a classic
for me it's acdc's i think four thousand
yep
i think released in like 77 or 78 78
and uh just great songs on there you
know a couple songs i had to stop and
re-listen to and go wow it's been a long
time since i heard this
and then i was outside you know taking
garbage out and sweeping whatever the
[__] i was doing in there
and youtube automatically switches
to the next album yeah if you don't stop
it
and all of a sudden i hear go down by
acdc
and i'm listening to this and i'm
thinking about high school
and sophomore year no no i'm thinking
about like freshman year and
and all of a sudden uh you know i don't
know what the order is on that doggy dog
yeah and then it's something else after
that and i think by the third song i had
to actually go in start the album
go to my bathroom in the back go outside
spark a bowl and i went back in and i
got a notebook and i sat down
and nobody was home it was like a rare
time and i listened to all eight of nine
songs on this album yeah
and you don't have to flip it over like
at home with an hour right
so
by the six song i actually had to stop
go get tissues
blow my nose and control my emotions oh
man i was angry with myself for various
reasons i was angry with myself because
i had forgotten about the sound yeah i
was
i was happy because
this album was like the [__] uh
it's it's like the four faces of the
president yeah oh rushmore this is like
one of my rushmores on my casket totally
this album really [__] like i i loved
highway to hell
and i loved powerade and i love tnt high
voltage
but let there be rock
just has something it has a different
feel to it you know
a great woman was once told me that
you the reason why she enjoyed zeppelin
and ac dc was because at every album
they grew yeah there was a different
sound everybody likes a certain band and
a certain album because of a different
sound they had and that shows you the
power of that [__] band which today
we don't have no more we don't have that
strength and for us you're going to
cover some bands that you said you've
watched lately
but that six album
seven album tenacious
to to show up seven times with
masterpieces yep and change your sound
around a little bit
is the real
brand whether it's comedy or music it's
the real brand of what the [__] we do
here growing you're growing you know
but
you see the growth from [__]
whatever the second album is dirty deeds
thunderchief well you got if you start
in the states it starts with high flying
high voltage and then it goes into let
to be rock but if you go like uh you're
traditional right it's like tnt right
you know you got high voltage you got
dirty deeds then you got the uh let
there be rock you got power raids then
you got highway to hell you know
you know i always i always talk about
floyd having those four power albums
zeppelin had those four power albums
this album is part of those four power
albums it's insane like it's it just
kicks off a barrage of debt
it's this
power rage and highway to hell
which kick off a barrage of [__]
death is it just like the amount of good
songs like what are you what are you
guys talking about this i'm talking
about the guitars the music the lyrics
light it up light it up dawg light this
[__] thing up you're talking about
them having everything is different the
songs are written from actual [__]
stories
that happened to the band they had a
singer by the name of bon scott god rest
his soul
that was one of the last true savages
like his style of of of living has died
it died with lemmy
you know these are guys that smoked and
drank till the end
they never gave up this was their life
this is who they were they drank they
did
you know i could uh go to youtube
but i want to sit here with you guys for
a second and even though the music is on
low
i don't think the speaker's on buddy i
think if you
if you wanted to what speaker
it's my life
is it maybe it's changing songs
here we go
yeah
doggy dog you know
all these songs and it's like
it goes from go down dog eat dog what
comes next and then it's um
there you go uh let to be rock my
favorite let that be rock then bad boy
boogie and bad boy boogie there's a
guitar part
in bad boy boogie yeah but i think it's
one of the most good most brilliant
guitar pieces right before bond scott
says uh i was born
to be from until the day i die whatever
just two lyrics that spook your [__]
spine yeah like all your neck hairs
stand up you know what i'm saying i love
that when it comes in on the day i was
born the rain fell down yeah no no no no
and it's brilliant writing
you know the other side has one of my
all-time listen if i gotta judge my
all-time favorite ac dc songs
number one is
give me a bullet to buy that oh yeah
that's number one that to me the lyrics
the content what he's talking about it's
coming from a real place if you know
anything about bonscott
number two
walk all over you and touch too much
destroy me night prowler yeah it
destroys my insides
uh what's on the power raids is that how
a song called
something about the moon oh what's next
to them what's next in the world
just pure brilliance if you look you
know rock and roll damnation
what's the other one and that's sin city
but there's another one on there
also a rage uh you got riffraff yeah
riffraff this is just classic yeah
guitar stuff now for this album here
this is a great jam but it warms you up
to hit it with let that be rocked oh god
damn
you know and just the statement that
they were making
if you look at the album cover it
doesn't even look real it looks like
they a kid in kindergarten
cut a picture out around them and put it
on a [__] thing
okay here we go so you were really into
like the whole experience like the whole
band from the from the people in it to
what they were wearing to to i didn't
give a [__] what they were wearing i
didn't give a [__] what they look like
i wanted them to make me feel something
when i go to a concert doesn't matter
lately you like the jews that jump up
and down right yeah you know why you
like them because they make you feel
something absolutely yeah okay
i think that the dj and all that stuff
and today like i can't go to a show
to watch a dj spin but i'm 54 years old
right i'm an old man you know that's not
what i cover
i want to see this i want to see four
guys five guys
go up to the stage and create this
you know when i was talking to dean
about it on the phone he made a great
point that
this album is dirty yeah
yeah well you know what the the what the
story is on this record
is
punk rock hitch in 77. that's not dirty
this is dirty people
they're australian
and
it's
it's chuck berry
on steroids absolutely
absolutely
and you know so here's the story
punk rocks big in 77
ac dc is playing quite a bit in london
they realize well we're not a punk band
but we need to keep up with this so they
write
dirty fast rock like this song here this
is so [__] fast when you think about
it listen it's just
you know what i mean it's it's hauling
ass
and you could see these they were
playing with punk bands you know right
there in london so this keeps up with it
right away compared to the high voltage
where it's like you know
like blues rock you know poker face was
her name
you know like the jack it's kind of
bluesy this is like straight punch to
the face get the [__] out of the out of
the pit man here we come you know you
know a lot of times you come on here and
i and we talk about different things
i talk about uh
if leonard skinner wouldn't have died
right music would have gone
yeah damn listening to this and i'm like
what would have happened yeah if bon
scott would have lived
because
back in black would have been a
completely different out oh man and it
was already written yeah it died it was
already ready to go was that [__]
ready to tape yeah you know i i can't
imagine how
hell's bells would sound yeah with bond
scott yeah right and and and have a
drink on me is such a bond thing you
know have a drink call me you know it's
so bond you know
and that [__] uh
also just back in black the actual track
hit the sack been too long glad to be
back it's just so incredible like it
would have been insane with him you know
because that record sold more records
it's up there with uh thriller and uh
the eagles you know so it's like imagine
with him like whoa
crazy
you know it was crazy like i lived
through all this like this is not
something that
like i still remember
it was a [__] cold day
and i did acid with this dude john
crowley and louis castellita
right yeah [__] it was freezing
[__] freezing and we went to this
park and
oh my god we just did so many that kid
john crowley he's a like a kids
illustrator today oh yeah but he used to
be top-notch entertainment whenever he
did drugs like he could just bust you up
yeah from picking up a cone with ants on
it and eating it in front of 200 people
like he had no fear about nothing yeah
but this one day he took his dick out
and got on top of a tree stump
that everybody sees is making this turn
and every time
people were driving past him he would
wave at him with his dick out
and we're on ass and laughing our asses
all
but the main thing was that that we
found out that night that bonds got died
it was like my 17th birthday when he
died yeah so i was in junior high you
know nobody knows nothing about nothing
in those days we had cream magazine like
i mentioned with you and jimmy
florentine yeah there was no internet no
there was no videos of ac dc rehearsing
that's not twitter and all of a sudden
one day out of nowhere
my people like bro we got tickets for ac
dc you're going oh my god
i thought the guy died i think he
replaced him the guy sounds the same
it's tremendous and again
it was one of those nights where we took
a bus over
we got coke from finn me and curtis
lorenzo god bless his soul yeah we were
weehawken and we got coke from this guy
jack flynn i told this story on him we
went over there and the coke was amazing
oh like it was cocaine like 1980. yeah
pablo escobar low speed yeah eyeballs
would get red
you know the alcohol really wouldn't hit
your body the coke would just clean it
up before it would start creeping yeah
but it was hot it was august 1st
of 1980 when they showed up and it was
hot yeah was it 80 80 80 80. it was hot
hot the tour has started in philly on
july 31st
so we call them early straight out the
box yeah august 1st and at that
palladium which is not a garden or a
meadowlands it's a theater
and def leppard opened up for them on
the [__] this is what i interested
yeah high and dry
no remember high and dry was released
like in 81 yeah but it didn't hit yeah
they had they won before they had the uh
on the night tonight at night yeah
so they're waiting for it to drop
they're probably out touring you know
that's how bands did it yeah they
[__] we went
and ac dc with brian scott that night
yeah was masterful oh i was there i saw
it i i saw the damage they did
guys i know how i felt when i left there
like
blown the [__] away coked out drunk
in those days we used to drink uh nips
but if i was with kurt we'd drink uh he
has two good friends yeah yeah yeah over
brown
brown low brown lips remember nickel
michelo michelob too i would go to
mickey's big mouth i had a friend that
was shaped like a mega little bottle
timmy holloway remember timmy hollow
my friend my friend roger it seems like
a makeup look
no no no these guys are tabascos yeah
this family lived next to the runnies
and they had five kids and one looked
like eddie van halen one was a biker one
was guy who's my goomba
one was uh i forget the one guy's name
that's kind of like a swear and then
there's the one guy that's a cop
and he's shaped funny he's shaped funny
sounds like a village people shoots like
a micheloba
jesus christ
what the fight is right in the tip of my
tongue but anyway the one that was the
cop had a funny looking body so raj used
to always call him a mickel obama
and she's like a little bit you should
say your brother you know timmy yeah
timmy the guy that you met yeah yeah
yeah yeah his bolder brother he's a
[__] eddie murphy dude like i'll put
him up with eddie murphy oh [__] even
today
born again christian halfway box he's
still naturally funny on the phone
and that's what he you know
what the [__] we talking about we're
talking about brian your friend that
looks like a bigger little bottle you
have drinking nips yeah he would just
acd he would go how long have you been
out here i was like for like four
minutes that [__] michelle obama
wanted to talk to me
that's how he'd refer to him
hilarious
i was just thinking about that i was
trying to work on a bit where you know
everybody wants bullion gone and it's
like there's not going to be any good
nicknames anymore you know like buck
teeth sam you know and uh laser breath
linda all these great nicknames people
aren't gonna enjoy those anymore no
they're a lot worse now those are like
but i'm just saying you know kids would
make fun of you now if you tried to call
malaysia brother linda they like kids
have the internet now they're probably
ruthless yeah but what i'm saying is no
nicknames will be around anymore because
they'll be like oh that's bullying you
know what i mean
but nicknames are gonna be gone
right
if you don't have a nickname you're
really not loved yeah i never knew that
wow my mother pointed that out that's a
great i [__] hated the name coco yeah
when i was old enough to live in
manhattan like when i was living on 88th
street when i was about six or seven
yeah i did not like the name [__]
coco but i had another predicament i
didn't like the name jose either yeah
yeah yeah so i started thinking about
like well wait a second my name is
antonio i'll just call myself tony yeah
so i even got a ring mate tony i had
tony put on everything i was like
[__] tony t-o-n-y tony that was it
yeah and my mother's like house antonio
and i would go no no my name is tony and
you go you know what tony go [__]
yourself you name it
[__] tony next i call myself tony
tony it looked like you were channeling
tony in that uh and that headshot the
comedy store put up the other night yeah
i love that with the glasses let me tell
you guys yeah i moved here on a [__]
monday yeah
and i had to take that picture on the
thursday yeah
because people are like you got a hedge
yeah you got a headshot you got a
headshot you got a headshot you got a
headshot
some guy that was a friend of her
friends yeah
took those pictures and the glasses were
the chicks i was dating over there just
let me borrow them for that yeah it's a
comedy headshot yeah yeah another
theatrical headshot yeah yeah well i
love uh that's one thing i love about
the store uh right now they're
rebuilding the bathrooms and we got to
get those headshots back up because
it really gives it that sense of uh
history in there because like even when
you look at early ones of ari shafir or
or early ones of uh you know uh steve
renazi all these guys from years ago and
you're like whoa look at how like uh
like they're almost straight like it
shows you what we look like the before
picture yeah yeah the before then you
look at this now this is 20 years ago
lied to
smoke blown up your ass yeah hollywood
abuse yeah hollywood abuse this is what
you look like is that why all headliners
seem to have like very like depressed
looking headshots oh like every
headliner has like a serious headshot
you know i look at that headshot i
looked at that last night i lost that
headshot that was in the car on my car
my apartment got [__] uh toad that
was your little headshot you had your
apartment
but at that time i always saved five or
six headshots right if you don't know
what what the [__] it's gonna be
and i uh i looked at that headshot
and i thought of one thing that i wasn't
as old as i thought i was when i moved
here yeah i was still a young [__]
kid man when i moved here i was
33 years old
bright and simple yeah yeah right
exactly i was a [__] young man and in
my mind i was
in hollywood's mind at that time that's
[__] old yeah yeah that's [__]
whole like more you're long in the tooth
you gotta lose weight yeah yeah you know
i don't know what we can do with you
yeah it was kind of [__] weird yeah
and i didn't i never took that to any of
them i didn't give a [__] what they had
to say to me it really never mattered oh
yeah i got a funny ass story for you joe
you're gonna love this morning you know
i've had no manager
seven years snow agent
so i do the ontario improv a couple
weeks ago do some good numbers
you know and then i do the san jose
improv do some pretty good numbers and
then i'm you know got this uh record
coming out so there's some you know
twitter stuff going and some management
people call me up just cold call out of
nowhere i'm sitting on my couch i don't
know this number uh that's it it's a
it's a conference call two managers and
they said hey uh hey it's such and such
and such and such uh you know we just
wanted to talk to you we've been uh you
know saw you did some good good stuff
you know coming up and doing some things
and uh
you know we want to know what you got
going on you know you got a manager i go
now i haven't had a manager and
the whole time and they go why do you
think that is and i go well i'm 51. it's
not an easy route nobody knows yeah
that's going to be work and what are you
going to do get you know 10 of my 1500
on a weekend nobody's gonna want to do
that and they go oh you know well we got
such and such and such and such and uh
you know we're really interested can you
send over some clips and i don't have
any clips but i had a
a good 30 i just shot at the la jolla so
i sent it over i don't hear nothing from
them right you're gonna love this i get
an email today
now taking mine they cold called me
right
they cold called me looking to manage me
when i sent them the video over
they sent back to me this answer right
here you're gonna love it
appreciate the follow-up we enjoyed your
stand-up but at this time we don't think
we have the bandwidth to start working
together and do what needs to be done
when launching a client we like to
ensure you we love to be 120 when we
work with someone we couldn't honestly
offer you that right now wish you the
best
they make it look like i contacted them
i didn't even come first of all don't
[__] just say i don't like your
comedy or we don't know what to do with
you but but they made it look like i
contacted them and they don't have the
time you got rejected for a job you
didn't apply for it
i'm like you should have just said you
know what we don't really dig this
isn't that hilarious
you know me i don't want to embarrass
nobody about eight nine years ago before
the podcast game even came along yeah
i got a call from like you ever get a
call from an assistant
oh yeah like an agent's assistant and
they go hey it says and such we uh yeah
i love that and she goes listen one of
my clients
would like to speak with you
about an opportunity i go
okay who's your client they tell me oh
yeah the back of my mind i've seen this
guy around town 10 times you're more
than happy to call me
saying okay we're going to loop him in
he loops in hey joey what's up last time
i saw you really funny i couldn't stick
around
i wanted to ask you something
are you being managed right now yeah and
i go no i got nothing else listen man
there's a manager at my manager's office
that [__] thinks
you're great that he loves you the
character
he worked with characters for eight
years over at such and such agency he
thinks he could really kick your acting
career and going yeah i go that would be
great this is [__] amazing i'm like
wow yeah today's my lucky day no more
[__] shitty agents yeah yeah yeah
they're a managing acting [__]
the real deal like these guys just have
like a bunch of [__] names
so i call the guy and he's like oh my
god it's a pleasure
you don't understand i've taken guys
like you this guy this guy in there
[__] again i'm like wow yeah this
seems a little weird he goes again what
do you have on hand
i got a reel i got this i got that i got
this let me send it over to you and get
this started he goes yeah let's get this
work going a week goes by
two weeks goes by yeah three weeks goes
by yeah finally you know me dog i'm a
cuban jew i got to pick up the phone
that's exactly what happened to me i
pick up the [__] phone right and i
dial the phone and i ask for him
and uh there's a long pause and he can't
talk right now is it okay if he calls
you back and sure enough the next day he
called
and he told me that
at this time man
me and my partner is disgusting i gotta
tell you something i could see you doing
great things
but it would be a long haul for us yeah
was so busy
with this and this and then why did you
make this poor
[__] actor
call me and embarrass himself yeah like
it's just
and this is
this is six or seven times yeah
you know last week i met with a guy that
as a friend
but we were exchanging stories and i
told him when i was shooting along his
yard
that at one time
uh what's his name
the black crazy guy
in the longest yard you know he got hit
by a [__] face oh tracy morgan morgan
tracy morgan in the process of that had
left three yards and he signed with a
management called handprint
and years ago
out of the [__] blue lee you ready
i'm ready i got a call from one of the
kids i grew up with
and he goes joe you got a minute i go
now i'm gonna listen
there's a guy in that way
that he wants to help you yeah like what
are you talking about you [__] won't
show me because i'm telling you
his father works on the docks and he
always talks about you his son seeing
you in l.a he knows you're from jersey
and he's a big time manager like we
think he handles jennifer lopez
i'm like what yeah yeah i'm like this
has to be [__] yeah yeah of course
sure enough he goes if can he contact
you or you want to contact him because
you know what i contacted him because
i'll call you back in an hour calls me
back gives me a guy's number i call him
up
bob joey how are you
oh my god i'm so happy listen jersey
loves jersey jersey loves jersey let's
do this yeah he's like dawg i love you
and this is like after spider-man 2
yeah before the longest yard
and he's talking me up about when is
your next showcase
i go when do you want it to be yeah he
goes how about thursday at 8 thursday it
is let me call you right back improv can
we do it yes for this and stuff
yeah they got that's who tracy morgan
left three yards for right
he shows up and sure enough two days
later you know what man
ah we work in comics that are a little
bit more high caliber than you yeah but
you just called all the way to new
jersey yeah my friend yeah so don't ever
feel bad not at all that kind of [__]
happens all the time isn't that crazy
too it's crazy i mean they called me
and the people at home were like what
the [__] is that the way that business
is
yes
it's we had a manager on here
maybe two years ago yeah and off camera
he spoke very highly of you
admit and he said like a dean doubt and
it's
funny dean because
i don't ever want people to get the
wrong concept but i got to tell you
something
if there's one person there's a couple
of people
doing it the right way today you see all
the people who succeed
and then you see all the underlings like
myself
dean
tom you know we're just striving to just
get
but we all share the same thing that
the funny thing about this town is you
could be the funniest guy in the world
but if people aren't coming to your
shows
that doesn't get the machine going no
the machine is all based on that for
years dean del rey
i did not know this yeah
because in the world the proof is in the
pudding
you know people have to come out and see
you they have to come out to support you
that spreads the word anything else
is obsolete it doesn't matter and what's
all the money and one shot into that
public eye
it's funny how
you could be doing this that this that
if they can't get a way to make money
out of you yeah they will not sign you i
had this discussion a couple weeks ago
with a young open miker
who uh
i think took offense to our conversation
because that explained the truth to him
yeah that
these people do not want to have contact
with you
until you're getting paid and they want
to come along and get paid and then you
become their best friend and everything
that happened the 20 years before that
is forgiven
yeah
it's forgiven
and sometimes you go joey why did you
forgive that guy because you know what i
got i got mouse to feed yeah and i don't
have time to argue with somebody over
talent you know what i'm saying yeah
about why did you put me in that movie
who gives a [__] the movie was a flop
anyway yeah burr told me the greatest
thing he said
you're gonna get a lot of no's
all the way up
and he goes but you're gonna get there i
can feel it and when you do
don't give all those no's a [__] you
because it's nothing personal it's just
business
you can't come into their life at that
time yeah
they have no space for you at that line
this happens with music you know it's
all the same listen this goes back i
always say a thousand times to the mafia
concert on friday
at the end of the week whoever shows up
with the biggest envelope could get away
with the most i'm watching the show the
other night about uh heroin and montreal
just yet i get home
from flappers or i think it was saturday
the ice house and
you don't want to start nothing it's
[__] 11 10 after 11. yeah you don't
have time to put two hours in you want
to be in bed by midnight you want to get
up on the lord's day
early and eat that canola oatmeal
quinoa quinoa oatmeal
so it was like 11 20 and i had to i go
yeah midnight i did the cbd all so i
gotta stay up for an hour anyway before
i fall asleep and there's this thing
about the
the montreal mafia wow and how they're
they did or they they hired the bikers
to do all the work for them like they
hide the hell's angels and that guy the
boss of the hells angels was a savage up
there
car bombs and [__] blowing people up
and [__]
but they distributed the heroin that
came in from
uh whatever yin yangville right and they
were contained in [__]
uh and then they would and they would
send half of that load to new york to
the bonanno crime family
and it's really interesting that you
watch all these tv shows and you read
all this
you know you deal you die and all that
all that [__]
was [__] because at the end of the
week
if lee struggling to give me ten
thousand dollars and you give me seventy
five thousand
even if i know you're selling drugs i'm
taking that money yeah i'm not gonna say
where'd you get the money from you how
much you give me from the drug operation
thirty thousand i'm not gonna take that
money take that out of the bag no yeah
so they all became like at the end of
the day they were all dealing drugs yeah
everybody knew to stay a [__] float
to really
let line your pockets with real money
you know they found out years later
after paul castellano that even the
underboss that dude had a heroin
smuggling operation in south jersey
that's the whole thing godfather's about
he didn't want to do drugs and they're
like dude you're an old man the booze
and the prostitution is over it's all
about drugs that's the whole story you
know
that's where the big quick money is yeah
and it's funny how there's a hypocrisy
it's the same hypocrisy
and music probably and it's a stand-up
comedy you could work your ass off you
could be a funny person
but until you start filling those seats
they really don't pay attention to you
yeah they refuse to pay attention to you
then they jump on the bandwagon
and they have options of how to teach
you how to sell more seats or
venues or things like that that's what
an agent does but in the beginning
i've said this a thousand times there's
not much people could do for you
you know your friends are bur you're
friends with marc maron
you know do you think mark marion just
grabbed you and put you in the show just
because you're young yeah i mean he gave
you a few episodes the same way he gave
me yeah yeah but people think like oh
let me just call mark and [__] we're
gonna go on the road and people come up
and go tell mark to put you more
episodes oh yeah
let me call mark right now
or they always say this one you ought to
be out in toledo you ought to come to
jersey you gotta come i go dude i'll go
anywhere
until i put butts in the seats the clubs
know they go this guy's filling rooms
get him immediately the phone starts
ringing the phone starts ringing yeah i
feel bad i get those things too to go
with joey but like joey can't fly me
across the country just to take edibles
and sit in the green room i mean it'd be
great but that's that's like you can't
just do do that but is it also
going back to what you were talking
about with the agents and stuff is that
why especially with you you're very
not that you you take as much you you
want to
strike while the iron's hot because you
know as soon as you stop putting people
in the seats they're going to drop you
too like
is that always in the back of your mind
just no no never
never
listen
once you was poor
and you struggled
for as long as i did doing comedy you
survived
yeah
because i survived life on the different
terrains
i survived through a valley of drug
dealers i survived through valley and
loan sharks yeah
couches couches
you know you got to remember where this
animal was [__]
caged all those years and who he was
dealing with so when i came out here
i can't say i got star struck
but i respected people who were bigger
criminals
than the criminals i grew up with
because that criminal is a talent yeah
you know what i'm saying they just wheel
and deal talent
yeah there's some people who do it
because they really enjoy stand up they
really really enjoy it they really enjoy
there's some people who put you through
a process
they take you they groom you a little
bit and then you're out there you're out
there till you're [__] dead
yeah you know which for some people
is great but somewhere in there you have
to take control of what's going on
and go this is my parameters this is
what i'm going to do and this is what
i'm not going to do
and that's where the success comes
if you look at one guy who did that from
the beginning it was a guy named daniel
tosh oh man daniel tosh is a strict
businessman [__] when you hire
daniel tosh at 40 minutes he's a memory
yeah that's it yeah 40 minutes he
doesn't do a minute over yeah or a
minute under and he's on that private
jet he's on that part of the jet to the
next [__] city he's a business dude
he's very
stern yeah with his business and it's
worked out for him that weighs that's
what you
have to do at times
sometimes you're going to go bank heads
with your management your agency
but if you believe it your conviction is
strong enough and you prove it to them
everything's fine yeah
you know again i'm 54 and i feel it yeah
i constantly look at you as the uh
you know like
inspiration you know like when i got
that email
i was just like
yeah it doesn't bother me because i just
did a record and i'm working you know
what i mean you you came to me and it's
like
i'm working tomorrow no matter what you
know what i'm saying it's first of all i
always thought a manager
was somebody you had to love
yeah okay i always thought a manager was
the type of person that would come up to
you and go dean down right joe diaz how
are you nice to meet you
dean
you're a great guy i'm watching you on
stage i hear nothing but great things
about you i really like to work with you
but at this level there's nothing i
could do i have a girl that books comedy
or guys for people
she books this guy this guy this guy
this guy
i'd like to get your resume started in
acting you know maybe get some ticket
sales put a couple cds out specials
let's work together for six months
no contract
you can leave whatever the [__] you want
you pay what i get you if i don't get it
for you you don't pay if your agent
calls you with a movie and you get 22
million dollars
i don't if i didn't get it for you you
don't pay me cool
and in those 90 days
i work a little harder for you
yeah i tell you a little more that first
i call you and go it's kind of dead out
there i've made some calls but i've made
big time calls like i've called in
favors
from friends that have a voice show for
voice or you know
because at the end of the day it's all
the same you know what i'm saying it's
luke makes the call yeah you know so if
you're a good manager you should have
three contacts
that i could call right now to get the
ball going to impress you totally right
i'm saying totally
so i spoke to my friends over at bill
burr's show you you know boom bear yeah
you know bill from the store yeah f is
for family yeah evans for family i got
you three episodes you're gonna play the
garbage man down the block okay because
he knows that one guy over there he
pushed you and he pushed you and he
pushed you you may not know bur
but he pushed you it's not up to burr
whatever
he knows people at netflix you know what
i'm saying yep then he'll call like a
theater somewhere
and get you in there for one night for
more money than you've ever dreamed of
like 1800 cash and a plane ticket yeah
and then he'll call and go do you have
an agent you're gonna know you all right
i'm gonna email you something print it
take that over tomorrow the caa go talk
to my friend matt frost over at see you
know i'm saying frosty yeah you go you
follow how yeah that's your manager now
you're surprised and you're like whoa
just in three weeks after that theater
i'm on f is for family i got an agent
then you're like wow this is real now
guess what yeah when you get that call
from mark maron and he takes [__] on the
road and he pays you in the good money
for theater money yeah who are you going
to pay a commission to when you get back
to managing with pride [__] yeah here
you go take 100 go get yourself a
haircut yeah yeah because you know
they're real and that's how you build
that bond
number two how can you do what you're
doing lately i'm watching you yeah i've
been watching you later i could see
somebody else like two or three other
people have mentioned you what you're
doing which is very smart you're going
you're right listen
you got you're 51 that means you got one
foot in the grave with a banana peel yep
you shouldn't even do jumping jacks
before lunch time yeah i'm saying just
in case yeah because our percentages are
a little higher yeah over 50. yeah but
right now
you're going for the juggler yeah you're
not [__] around with movie or
commercials you said [__] it i'm going
for a clientele i want to let people
know they come for an hour they get a
great show blah blah blah when i'm not
doing this
i'm learning with bill burr and marc
maron and joey and [__] jim jeffries
and you know yeah eliza whoever the [__]
says to you you want to go on the road
and work which is the best education you
could i did it for years totally i
headlined shitty rooms for [__] years
and i'd open up for joe there's no ego
there i don't have no [__] eagle i
don't give a [__] i love him the ego is
the [__] bank book you know what i'm
saying yeah i'm paying my bills i'm
paying rent i'm eating i'm smoking
reefer you know i'm not [__] kevin
you're doing kevin hart but i'm [__]
uh making a living which isn't bad
you're gonna put the other side on want
me anything we need another star we
don't look high enough today i know what
the problem is i know he needs another
[__] bonk in a debt i'm high as [__]
i don't look high not at all okay
[__] it don't look high at all it's time
for you to see the devil the spots
haven't come out yet tonight no spotty
you took the medication
yeah
you took the spotty
yes
this is side [__] two
of the classic let that be rock
the back side of this is angus young
with like a weird light color like a
amber amber like an almond color like
that lip kicked up
the sg
the schoolboy suit you look at it and
you go oh there it is right there like
he just came on you know it's still got
all the outfit on
now you and i have had discussions about
bands before yeah and after
because for a week i listened to this
album yeah and i broke down every song
and i thought about it and i wrote jokes
while i listened to it right spoke on
the phone to people when i had it on low
and i send certain videos to certain
friends of mine on facebook like
think about this [__] yeah how
good is this [__] yeah how many likes
that we listen to [__]
over over whatever overdose on you in
the [__] this
i realized something then i started
watching a couple brian brian johnson
brian johnson videos and i came to a
conclusion that's really hurtful
[Music]
till this day yeah
ac dc was done when bonds got done
brian johnson those guys were something
else yeah and i tolerated back in black
i got sucked into the with the ether
for those who sucked the [__] i love
that time i love that record by that
time i had done it
yeah for those who sucked the car
we salute you by that time i had the
hour my shoplifted the album yeah
shoplifted the album but once i brought
it home out of respect the ether had
wore off i love it i loved the first
three brian
back in black those about to rock and
flick of the switch
i love this yeah then i watched a brian
johnson concert
that was spectacular in 80.
when the [__] it was mtv it was
packed
and they were all dancing for this and
they had to be 60 000 people oh [__]
that's like that germany wanted yes yes
that [__] is killing and it's killer and
i'm like you know what
even though they're ripping it up
it's still not and i read a lot of the
youtube comments yeah oh my god you went
down that hole i had to i had to see
what people were saying about and you
have no idea how many people
felt the same and i never
realized this until two weeks ago when i
saw all the videos that night i'm like
and that's why i got out of it after a
while i get it a lot of people started
replacing people listen deep down inside
in my [__] soul yeah there was no way
i was going to listen to d.o sabbath oh
man if you know anything about uncle
joey i refuse to taste hummus i will not
listen to theo sabbath okay it's my
favorite but yeah they made me [__]
turn it around yeah but it seemed like
so many bands
once a band's hero leaves it's over i
feel like that was scattered man i just
couldn't take oh no i i would not it's
just it's just a sin you know they're
just out there they got the nephews and
the cousins and the guy who lives sister
his uncle
i love leonard skinner but you gotta let
them let them rest their soul yeah i
can't have that it looks like a [__]
barnyard
something it doesn't look good ac dc is
down to one original guy now angus
everyone's gone
and and
we're like what's gonna happen
and you know there's rumblings that axel
may do a record with them but you know
phil rudd's out who was the drummer you
know he got all messed up last year he's
out so and then the bass player once
brian was out the bass player clip
williams said i retire i've been here 40
[__] years or whatever i didn't think
it was going to be this long so it's
just angus now and they're going to go
out again you know like imagine the
power
of one guy in a schoolboy outfit
selling out an arena the power of that
like we don't care who's in there we're
going to see angus isn't that wild
i mean that is us that is a strong
[__] character
i don't know there's very few people
that could do that though like can you
imagine
like this newbie well he's gonna sell
out for sure right if he has axel right
axel is the obvious [__] replacement
right right now raxel right wants to do
it yep you know if axel could cut a deal
with guns and say i'm with you guys six
months yeah take a month off and then do
three months with them a quick
three-month tour like two shows a week
they gotta rest everybody's in their 60s
i mean angus is what sixty-seven i think
he's 64 or something look that up lee
will ya sure
angus young yeah he's the young one of
the band you know i mean he was in the
band when he was like [__] 14 you
know
what we got he is a
uh young 62 years old 62 because he was
in as a kid you know like 13 14 years
old
isn't that weird like i always said like
we're speaking about managers and we're
speaking about the business and all that
growing up in rock
it was really brutal because you would
go into the room and they would go we
look we love your band
but the bass player is fat
and the uh the drummer's old got to get
rid of them and we'll sign you and and
it would be like a brotherhood of dudes
that played for like 10 [__] years
together and they're like sorry dude you
know and they would it was just brutal
you would hear that
my point is
i don't know how ac dc ever made it
because you got a guy who's like 13 but
then bond is like [__] 30.
and when you look at the guy and none of
them are good looking so
i don't see how a label went like yeah
we're cool with this your singer's old
as [__] you're like you know what i mean
that's crazy to me
oh everything was against them a lot
like metallica metallica playing a music
that no one knew no one heard of they
kind of invented this speed metal and
they're four
not good-looking dudes during the
[__] full glam era of rock
you know and they and they make it
i love that that's what keeps me driving
you know what i mean
it's like people go they'll never make
it it's like
it's not about making it it's about
doing it right
it's about doing it and living it yeah
like for me
you know from 2007 2008 i was struggling
2009 you know dude i was picking up this
i was seeing you at the [__] ha ha
you know what i mean and you're coming
down doing tuesdays like an 09
you know what i mean and and
you know yeah i was there in 09 and uh
at the end of 09 and i remember like
augustine always be like yeah that's
that's joey diaz man you ever see him i
was like no you know what i mean you
come walking down the street i was like
no and then you know i start
seeing you all the time later on i start
hearing your name then i start then you
come back to the store and i'm like wow
the magnitude of this you know what i
mean and then i start looking at it as
like that guy's a [__] a lifer
you know what i mean what do you have to
be yeah whenever i see a guy that's a
lifer like you know like me
i've been
in the entertainment business 35 years
this is just what i do you know like
music now it's comedy or whatever but
it's like [__]
lifers man you know listen man i became
a lifer
i can tell you this with all the honesty
in the world
i became a lifer in october of 93.
that's when i knew there was a certain
point i said okay
i've done it all
i'm going for this
to me at that time with the going for
this meant just to
live it to do it whether i starved yeah
or whether there was lobster or [__]
a veggie and cheese sandwich from subway
sandwich on a joint yeah i would be
happy as long as i wasn't robbing and in
prison exactly that's how i looked at it
that's how i narrowed it down i said
i'll never forget that decision i'll
never forget
flying driving back to colorado with a
woman i barely knew yeah
cross country and thinking like i can't
wait to get to denver
to start
doing comedy
i had the judy carter book i had watched
the bet tape of
of joe torre warming up with uh the
little guy with martin yeah i had
watched rodney dangerfield specials i
had been doing comedy for two years
doing whatever that's called in the
beginning limbo period that yeah you
don't really know what the [__] you're
doing you're just out there yeah you're
just out there yeah but it took probably
28 months to realize
that i was going to be a lifer i could
tell you guys that right now yeah that's
without when i went back to boulder i
said this is [__] it
and nothing's gonna [__] stop me that
was it
that's what [__] rules you know what
i mean that's yeah like
yeah it was either i was gonna end up on
the stage yeah well i was gonna end up
back in prison or dead yeah that was it
i had made my decision up like there was
no i wasn't now don't get me wrong i was
not thinking success no if you want me
to look in the eye and go yeah yeah i
planned on doing uh the wilton theater
in
yeah 2000 that's [__] yeah that's
[__] yeah i never planned on success
i planned on surviving yep a small
apartment
maybe a couple rats in there low over
you know low overhead
no car maybe train and feature acts
would drive me if i ever became a
headliner you know
i knew i was always good enough to
feature yeah but headlining is something
[__] different it said i respected it
you know what i'm saying like even
though i didn't respect the law i didn't
give a [__] about drug dealing [__]
about a lot of things i respected
headline yeah you know i respected the
light in the beginning
and i knew that the more i got on stage
the better i would get like i just knew
it yeah i just [__] knew it yeah yeah
that's what you're doing right now
exactly you don't give a [__] you'll
jump on a plane in the back of jet blue
to 299 and sit behind a fat dude like me
farting the whole way yeah you'll go to
the stand you'll go here you'll go there
you'll sleep on the couch that's what
being in and you
it's so easy to crack at that time in
your life oh man i've had some close
ones yes
very easy to wake up in the middle of
night and go oh yeah i'm sleeping on
somebody's couch
and he's in there smoking crack what am
i doing my life yeah it's just
and you come you you really
this business the ups and downs is uh
unbelievable you know what i mean like
like one day you're on russell peters
private jet the next day you're at
[__] sardos doing an open mic you
know what i mean there's no illusions
those are all people's draws and you're
you're just uh lucky enough to be able
to be on one of those you know uh but
you see the magnitude
and what kind of work it takes to get
there which is kind of cool that i i get
to be around guys like you or marin or
these dudes i've been in 20 30 yeah
you're around like you're around big
leaguers marin yeah like marin was big
when i got into comedy already like
marin
was well known yeah and there was two
marc marons you know that right
yeah for a long time there was mark
maron
and mark
moran [__] oh yeah yeah the other guy
would end up being like a joke thief oh
wow and they were a couple people send
them subpoenas and [__] wow just stop
doing his jokes yeah subpoena yeah like
they subpoenaed them like what's that
called season exists yeah yeah season
this is exist yeah yeah yeah
yeah i guarantee lee look that up that's
crazy spelled the same way
maybe with a k or
something able to see yeah or marks with
the c so maybe with a k
i'll try that first something like that
you're right i'm just i know it's not
but i'm just imagining a picture of marc
maron with like
like the fake uh glass glasses yeah
that's just coming up with mark maron
now like not like the famous one did you
try m-a-r-k
and they're like no you mean this one
another one comes up i'll put an
off-search instead for mark okay
yeah when i first started 95 there was a
problem
mark was in san francisco i think right
and the other guy was in michigan wow
and the other guy did colleges but he
would do the clubs and rob jokes
oh you found it yeah no no no
and then you do you would do something
something like that right yeah so i had
heard of mark could be like an e or an
anthony you know when i first started
yeah when i first started i still
remember mark yeah i remember uh jay
moore yeah was already big in new york
so was the black kid bill
bellaby oh bill bellamy bill bellamy was
already big in new york
mitch was around right
uh
mitch came a little couple of years
later like i met mitch in seattle
louis ck in seattle wow the other kid
that died that was really funny
he was from bell hex no no no no no
just uh he was like a new york guy
uh-huh louis c kane he died god
god bless his soul he died from that
stuff you get
when you get leakage in your ears
i don't know and he was getting married
so he went to the emergency room but it
took too long oh wow so he got on the
plane he died on his honeymoon something
crazy oh man something's crazy i don't
forget what his name was but he was i
met him in seattle i met janine garofalo
seattle tom rhodes in seattle
yeah and like 95 town roads was already
big right felicia michaels was already
playing
before yeah you know in those days they
had comedy kamikaze and they had
comedy justice yeah mtv comedy hour oh
yeah yeah yeah vh1 sunday comics where
they would put three 20-minute sets
pitbull yeah satan yeah bobby slate
you know hbo was more prevalent with
comedy you know yeah so you know when i
first got into comedy i mean i studied
those types i went to flappers last
night yeah and there's a young kid that
works there like a waiter he works hard
and i told him last night he goes i
watch this
and i enjoy when this guy said this and
that's how i know you really love comedy
when you watch different comics
and you learn certain things from them
on paper like he was saying he watched
this and this guy's told the story and
how he went into the story and i'm
watching this kid going this kid can be
dangerous because he's like 19. yeah
yeah these are the guys that learn this
[__] working on stage and by the time
they're 24 they're ripping it up nobody
knows who they are then they get to be
26 27. yeah and now these guys are mad
at the [__] stage i could see this
kid being a killer yeah yeah because
even though you got so much [__] you can
watch now too before we'd have to wait
we'd get a vhs
yeah and you'd watch it and then like
maybe go to blockbuster or whatever your
corner store was and and get another one
like i got another video i'm gonna watch
this guy but now you just youtube and
you know like uh this week i decided you
know
i'm starting to write some more stuff i
go i want to try to get into some really
good storytelling style you know because
i love like al magical or you you guys
you tell these stories that have the
bits and i have all these stories from
life and i really want to try to bring
them into the show but figure out how to
punch him up you know so now i'm gonna
i'm watching like story guys you know
what i mean it's you pick stuff to
really uh learn so you have all the
weapons you know like you know
one-liners uh dirty jokes storytelling
uh whatever you know
it's all different
you know
stories is a weird one it's hard stories
is a weird one because
you have stories
that are very funny right you have
stories that are funny we'll drop this
off here
we give some shout outs and
it's funny how we all have stories
and we have stories that
are [__] naturally funny but we don't
want to tell people because it shows our
shortcomings yeah
you know i can't tell people by the time
i my mom used to give me when i was like
three
and like my my dad first died my mom
would come home at night because she'd
take me to the bar
so i'd be jazzed up at three in the
morning so my mom would drink italian
red wine
and she would drink a little glass and
then she'd give me a sip yeah and one
night i watched her pass out and i said
[__] i'm going to get back that glass
that was something good in that [__]
bottle
sleeper hold and i went i drove the
[__] bottle like i just drank
whatever was in there
and my mom said she woke up in the
middle of night she couldn't find me she
called the cops and they found me in the
closet
puked with [__] in my pants and i'm a
[__] deal
and that's why i didn't drink for years
because of that red wine oh yeah but who
would say that story about themselves
right right do you follow me that's the
humor in it when you're telling
uh an awkward story i always want to
tell a story that has a payout at the
end yeah yeah i want you to see what i
[__] learned and those stories aren't
usually very funny yeah i know all right
they're not funny yeah
but there's always little highlights of
what happened that are true
that'll be funny and yeah we've just got
to really think
and rewrite it and rewrite it and
rewrite it and rewrite it and rewrite it
and then
yeah it really works out but you have to
write a lot of stories you do so what
you have to do is get up
the easiest way to write a story is to
go to facebook and just what is that
blog post right and force yourself to
write a blog
every monday morning it has to be ready
just put up a story yeah yeah yeah one
week for music one week from comedy one
week from a concert one week from your
youth maybe something you saw at your
house that always struck you kind of
weird when i first moved here doug
stanhope
would tell me every day in 1997
to start writing my life wow i wish i
would have paid attention to him
because today i would have been steven
spielberg yeah just rewriting everything
i would look at him in my life who the
[__] why would i write my life out as
depressing yeah yeah that's a that's a
great great uh recommendation yeah and
now tony you know i finally took his
advice yeah
when i was in the comedy 19 years or
something like that yeah 18 years then i
said wait a second he's on to something
i'm going to start doing that because
what happens is while you're writing
stuff about your life
uh memories come out
like it dust the cobwebs off and you're
like oh yeah that's right i got a couple
buddies that didn't party as hard as i
do so they come around and they you know
like if i ever write a book it'll be
like motley crue the dirt where i'm
telling a story and then the two buddies
are on chapters too you know like oh
yeah what happened was you came over
here and you did you know and then they
can aerosmith style yeah harrison's the
first from the first uh
that would be interesting also but it's
also
always great to just try to master
you know you start with two paragraphs
yeah and every day you look at it for
one hour
one hour and you'll see that
some days at the beginning
but by the end you'll write one tag and
that's fine i've been forcing myself to
do that lately and it's kind of been an
adventure and just go down there because
i got to tell a story on june 20th yeah
what did you pick one yet yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely yeah so it's
pretty funny i'm i'm combining three
yeah
okay there's a certain like you i need
20 minutes
yeah so if i do the first one
it'll be six minutes oh you'll tell me
to go [__] myself right if i do the
second one
the second one will probably be like
three minutes
the last one is going to be heavy duty
and that guy can milk that to 10 minutes
right so if i combine all of them i give
him 22 23 minutes he could cut off five
or six
in editing and we have something yeah
yeah
i tried it at in uh colorado
sunday i was like all right i got the
record you know i got it in a can and uh
i did an hour and then at the end of the
hour
i go you guys want to hear some new
stuff they're like yeah yeah so i went
into this tesla story and i've only done
it four times about opening for the band
for tesla
and uh
i felt great
and i was i was remembering stuff from
it that i didn't before and it got it
got good all of a sudden and it was
getting good it didn't matter if you
didn't know the band tesla or anything
that's my whole way of trying to do the
story if you don't know the band tesla
it's not about that it's about
your rock and roll dreams getting
squished you know what i mean and uh man
i felt great you know and and i know you
just need to do the stories more and
more to get them good well here's the
secret yeah here's the secret you ready
yep you have to write out the story
before you go on stage
just that particular story and what
you're going to do is you're going to
put it in after 20 minutes of your
material yeah so they're totally in love
with you by that time you already got
them on your side you warmed them up you
fingered them by this time no matter
what you throw at them
they're on your page you've hypnotized
them you've taken them under the ether
you've taken them in and out they got a
few cocktails in them they're rock and
roll and you're reminding them in 1979
then you drop your story
and it's funny because what you
might have on the tip of your tongue
while you're writing
will come out when 200 eyeballs are
watching you yeah
see a lot of people don't realize the
pressure of the eyeballs yeah yeah yeah
during the headlights
and they teach you how to write jokes
ladies and gentlemen when you look out
into an audience and you see 200
eyeballs looking at you
you get real [__] creative paid
eyeballs you get like two cop in the
room creative yeah i'm saying yeah yeah
so where were you four in the morning i
was walking up los cienega and i made it
right on that you know you get like
there was a jewelry store like you get
specific yeah you know if you're
innocent you're going to be specific you
understand me so that's the way you have
to think about it in a way you have to
so when you go up there it's real funny
so if you do it five nights in a row
by the end of the week you have two or
three new tanks and you'll have openings
yeah you're right there man like i i
have to call flappers and the ice house
to get wet thursday night rooms
thursday night i'm home for five weeks
i'm utilizing every [__] thursday
i'll go with it man
i'll try stories you have to
work that muscle
and they have to understand it's a
workout type of night total
so i i enjoy doing that i enjoy writing
the story out i'll try that and then
going wow let me go on stage with it
you know i enjoy doing spots at the
store
and i enjoy doing flappers but i gotta
tell you what last week i did two hours
i did an hour at the
i did i were up in bakersfield
at uh
tumblr tumblr brewing company which is a
[__] great place yeah great comedy
place trying to get yourself booked i
will it's a rock and roll type of place
and uh [__] strong beer
like it's like twelve percent you drank
some beer no but everybody else around
me like [__] babies
[__] up yeah yeah but it's funny how
different it is to do 15 minutes four
nights in a row
then doing two hours two nights in a row
it's such a different animal so i'm done
i'm done i can't
when i get stuck in town it takes like
the first weekend who has me on the road
it's brutal for them on thursday night
yeah because that's the first hour i
[__] do in a month or four weeks
which as a headliner you cannot do that
to yourself i was just talking to you
you cannot do that to yourself so i'm
done with it
instead of chasing [__]
every night going to spots [__] you i'd
rather just work the muscle the full
[__] muscle so you know where you
stand you go up on stage you charge them
five bucks a tuesday night and you
[__] talk to your asshole's purple
yeah and they opened up a little open
mic around the corner here it's like
eight to ten chairs oh no booze couple
sodas it's next to a sushi place oh yeah
with the rats over there you know what
i'm talking about it's got the z rating
you go in there they give you a [__]
discount at the hospital oh my god
just you you use code sick and they give
you a discount at the hospital let me
give some shout outs real quick how
about my man
joe conchetta whatever your [__] name
is your buddy told me to give you a
shout out [__] patrick burgerham
ralph lauren cameron swordmayer
danny mendoza
david pence or perez i don't know make
your choice
shout out to both i gotta [__] know
your name now rg madden
j rama loving you chris o'hara
robert breed and my main man
johnny lettuce
dante gazzini you know what i'm saying
dante who's better than you do not
forget like i told you [__] on
the periscope
that uh
tickets for sadly even though the golden
state warriors are playing utah they're
pretty much close to sold out so if you
don't get them by now you have to sit
friday [__] early show at eight
o'clock that's when the mormons are
coming with the drums they're giving out
business cards i love that crap that
club is phenomenal i was [__] excited
about going there what are you nuts or
what some of your life no parole sucker
dean del rizzi and [__] oh man
cds yeah i did a vinyl smacking [__]
uh
road rash i'm calling it
it's good for you man i'm very [__]
excited to call yourself a friend you're
a hard worker i love you dad and
somebody else in this town is walking
around
waiting for something to [__] hit him
in the head with a brick yeah and i
really gotta tell you
like me i said that at least
actually when i just jumped like a
breaker
oh my godly
well you need another star i'm watching
it i love it man you know like i was
telling marin i go you remember you
you know yeah i i beg to open for you
guys because it's the hang we don't get
to hang at all i was telling eric
griffin that today came over and did the
podcast which by the way incredible show
uh dying up here that uh showtime show
coming out uh you know about the store
that book and everything eric's in it
and uh santino
and uh el magical it's coming out and i
saw a couple episodes i felt so proud of
those guys but i was telling
you know it's about like
i i you know at 44 i didn't have these
friends
and now i have these new friends for
like the last seven years and and i just
want to hang because you know i'm single
and everything and everybody's busy but
i'm like man let's hang and listen to
wreck or whatever so when i go on the
road with you or mark or burr or
whatever it's like it's just a great
hang you know like to be out there and
like hey let's hit this record store you
know that comes with marina denver i'm
like oh i scored this you know and he's
over there scoring he scored some crazy
record he just liked the cover we threw
it on we're like what this is incredible
it was some band and we're like listen
to this guy sounds like rod stewart it
was rod he was singing on this dude's uh
record that played with the stones and
stuff as a studio musician and yeah
what's that ian mclaughlin no no i'll
get i'll get it for you let me look up
the photo was this uh it was this dude
we'd never heard of and it was uh you
know that kind of stuff i love
the hang you know
um
it's just it's just so it's just so
different you know let me find this
record oh my god it was like i was like
what is this wrecker
lee maybe you can fire it up too so it's
so funny that i started giggling as as
soon as lee's started smiling
he knew i was watching
he did the shoulder shake stop somebody
you don't even know no i don't need to
eat another store look at the shaving me
right now there's nothing wrong with you
we ate 11 stars don't eat it
i had 11 stars and the blueberry thing i
tricked you yeah no you didn't trip me i
counted that's the skinny one yeah
goddamn those stars smell good
it dropped on the side of me there oh
good it's on the floor no don't worry
we'll eat that one later here
we'll eat that one later
why are you throwing him like a baseball
gotta get him for tomorrow i think it's
nice and hard tomorrow i got to find
this the tac is on [__] fire on that
thing
where the [__] is this record man oh
bombing i don't see the photo i took a
photo of it so i buy it
sucks
you ever notice that like you look at
your thing and the photos just seem to
disappear
did you find it no i don't know
i found the record oh wait i think i see
one i think i see one check this out
joey python lee jackson here's the cover
it looks like nothing right it just
looks like a dylan record or something
absolutely he just [__] scores this
we put it on
the record's called in a broken dream
right by a computer right there see
one fell right out of this guy harry's
the [__] day
he's got some hair
don't worry about nothing
you're still running me look this up
python
python leaves jackson yeah check this
guy out man he played with the stones he
played with rod stew all these guys so
when he did a record he just cashed in
and had all his buddies come play on it
and uh marion got it for three dollars
this record is [__] worth getting it
looks like this python lead check you're
gonna love this joey it's like it's like
faces
sounds like the faces it's like dirty
blues
interesting yeah i know i couldn't
believe it man and it was so funny i
were like oh this guy's totally ripping
rod stewart and then we look later and
it says guest vocalist rod stewart we
started crazy though
i guarantee if you look that guy up yeah
he was from close to that that recording
studio where leonard skinner recorded on
muscle shows and the stones recorded and
they also recorded at a [__]
different studio in tennessee yeah
somewhere at the stone somewhere in
nashville or memphis right right it's
memphis they recorded right oh yeah like
the the sun studios yeah something there
yeah these are those guys that they
spoke about in those books there it is
right there we're [__] tremendous
right tremendous you're like who are
these guys that's just they just
probably had heroin addictions yeah and
they couldn't keep it together but
you're telling me that tuesday we'll
save you a bag
of the good [__] the shakit richards did
yeah listen to this [__] yeah turn it up
[Music]
seventies rock
please eat the [__] thing already
there's hairs on it it's fine
the hair's a good feeling
that's okay the hair is a good people
put some water on it go ahead
eat the [__] thing multiple people
every day i spend my time
[__] great
because you're going to [__] around all
weekend
and tell me fairy tales that i only ate
11 steins
i don't know what happened how many
stars can a human eat
because that's when you got to go deep
it's on friday and saturdays i do i take
10 stars usually no you don't i call you
you give me some [__] story
i have 1400 wow
you just went under the [__] thing
oh [__] you got chocolate left too
that's still a blueberry
what's not to do with blueberry did you
eat that [__] thing yet where is it
it's in its mouth what's in your head
black stuff don't be pulling a zucchini
don't they taste like yummy gummy bears
man i mean why are you always choking
not 12 in
one thing oh [__] but
we still got some more left in this [__]
it could be d-day for both of us
how do you like this man
it's cool very
[Music]
vomit launch
[Laughter]
this is the most coherent i've seen
leaves
something with those thoughts
no double acid one of the good ones
oh my god wait a minute let me tell you
something
most people need to go to comedy clubs
to laugh yeah
i don't think this is he's the funniest
guy i know right yeah
he makes me laugh on the nights like i
can do a show
like we could get him high just put a
camera on lee i narrate over it what i'm
thinking
and then put it up once a week a half
hour show the lee dog show the lead dog
show him just get eaten [__] 2 000
milligrams and all the changes he goes
yeah but my left eye is watching them
like
okay
and i see him look up and oh my god
breathe heavy and i can see what his
mind is thinking about and then he'll do
that he'll give you one of these
yeah sometimes he gives you jewish guilt
yeah
the first one is the jewish guilt if my
mom sees this whatever i don't i've
never once said that no you didn't have
to say it but you thought about it
just because you didn't say it don't
mean you're not thinking about it
does your mom watch the podcast at all
she can't get through the opening thank
goodness
it does she likes it it's just it's not
no she can't watch this and it's good
yeah it's good
i don't teach her how to do it oh god
yeah you don't want your mom to worry
i don't understand like the other day i
went to do a show and a kid
some girl talked to this kid before he
went on stage and the pregnant
girlfriend was there
and she ran up to the stage and was mad
and he came to me and i go this is why
you don't bring your girlfriend to the
[__] comedy show yeah especially if
she's eight months pregnant
there's work and there's bus you know
what i'm saying yeah
i'm going to work you don't go to work a
lot of people don't
uh understand that at first i don't
understand that concept
until something goes down with your wife
or your girlfriend same with rock and
roll i always had this rule you know no
girls no girlfriends you know they're
like why man it's like dude this is like
we're here we're here at work and they
they just distract
they want to light you a cigarette next
you know they want to play the [__]
tambourine yeah yeah w [__] play the
tambourine if i wanted a tambourine
player i would have hired one in the
[__] loop in newsweek tambourine yeah
everybody wants to be a [__]
tambourine player
i don't need no tambourine play how you
doing my little brother lisa
i know it's early league i shouldn't be
asking
but what do you got planned for the
weekend
for this weekend yeah what are you what
are the big plans let's hear this
[__] hoopla of death
yeah it's early dude i haven't even i
haven't planned [__] to be honest that's
why i love you you're very spontaneous
she comes home she tells you you want to
go to pismo beach
yeah i was the one who found pismo beach
people which is great i can tell you
found pismo beast that's right you're
the type of dude that would find pismo
beach however he goes i i already found
pismo i just found it he smells beach
he found pismo beats through yelp no i
didn't i found him by driving up the
coast what was this when i when i went
to go set up the studio what studio at
the uh
team's roads are home school that's
right home school anyway oh you want to
hear this new band these kids i want to
hear about you brother i want to hear
about you forget the bands all right if
i want a [__] dick what's his name
who's that what's american band's name
oh uh uh dick carr if i want big clunk
i'm [__] summons
where you at this weekend
this weekend i'm at the store all
weekend are you doing a lot of traveling
yes or no you're on the road oh man it's
scary right now i got a whole [__]
summer of nothing
nothing i'm just like wow
the whole
i got i got uh uh with you
and then nothing after that
which is like scary man i might call
that's good because
everything good comes last [__] are they
doing oddball again no it doesn't look
like this year i think they're going to
take a year off i mean i could be wrong
but i haven't heard anything you know
um
i wish man that would be great to get on
something like that you know any chance
of you popping on this def leopard
poison tour oh seven minutes that would
be great
i think they should get i know my
my friend john salami was supposed to be
doing
the photography like helping out oh yeah
uh during the tour i know they're on
tour yeah they are i've heard it a
couple times on uh they're playing where
the [__] out there by uh where the us
festival was you know like out there by
ontario improv
okay yeah they're out there i'm i'm uh
may 21st i'm doing rock on the range
with jim brewer and metallica
that's [__] cool no where's that in
columbus ohio
uh one nighter you know uh rock on the
range is three days one day soundgarden
headlining the next day is uh corn and
the third day is metallica i'm doing the
metallica day jesus [__] fired up all
all these bands are on there that i love
like gorgira
rival sons
uh all these great [__] bands are
playing that day and you get that killer
all access i'll just i'll try to get
some podcasting going on after my set
with some rock stars you know and uh and
enjoy metallica man i can't wait to see
that you know it's funny because when i
called you and i said listen i was all
high one night and i called dean i go
dean
here it is when you come back we're
doing [__] let there be i told no i'm
lying to you people i go dean i listened
to an album that changed my life
i'm embarrassed because i forgot about
this [__] album yeah and you're like
what is it you know i'm like let that be
wrong you're like listen
why do you think i named my podcast that
why do you think i have a tattoo of my
body yeah because it's that good and i'm
like jesus at least there's and i called
some friends at home
and i suggested that one of my friends
call me back and he goes oh my god
he goes i found myself crying yeah
because i found myself in a parking lot
we used to go to the binghamton boat
there was this boat that was ratty when
we were kids you oh
you could take your girlfriend out to
dinner there but nobody went to dinner
we just went back there to drink beers
and maybe get a hand job and stuck your
teeth or something out in the way that
yeah but you could hear the rat
scratching
no the bottom of the car the rats from
the hudson river oh it was one of the
scariest [__] things
you could ever ima you know like you're
sitting there making out with a girl
and you hear like can you hear me
yeah yeah
like they would make little noises yeah
and they'd be like three or four of them
out there but they would be ginormous
that'd be the size of my [__] cats
scratching to get in the [__] car the
subway rats like you see in new york
how many
how
it is
listen man the rap problem back there
that i have friends that live in like
fancy buildings and they say that the
rats start to come out at five in the
afternoon no there's something where do
they come out they don't come around in
their apartments do they
no at the parks with their kids okay
it's crazy yeah overlooked
i don't go to parks no you would never
go sometimes i'm walking home from the
stand wherever i'm staying and they got
garbage day and there's just thousands
of garbage bags on the street people
understand in new york you just they
just you put your garbage on the street
they pick it up and you'll be walking
all said like what what the [__] there'd
be like three of them battling over an
old piece of pizza and you're like oh
you scared the [__] out of you and they
just look hey like get out of here we're
eating you know bro i hate all that [__]
i see a rat a mouse oh i'm done that's
why i'm happy i got cats i'll take that
cat piss smell and to find the right you
wake up at two in the morning high as
[__] you got a sip of soda you look on
your counter you see a little you see
mickey mouse on your [__] counter
yeah nothing shocks your value like that
and then like a week later you see two
or three of them oh yeah that's when it
gets ugly when they start multiplying
quickly and then you're doomed yeah red
ben had that [__] problem in his
apartment
and he had the camera set up and you
could watch him the one trap hit the one
it was like yeah
and it got away and it was like [__]
it just paralyzed havoc's body
oh it's epic that [__] is [__] crazy
the screaming it's doing it's going
and he actually picks the [__] thing
up with his little feet and sticks his
head out and you see him limping out lee
it's hysterical yeah he's like i'm out
of here you [__] [__] you
sent a trap and his cousins are yelling
from where are you at yeah don't come
back here
they got [__] landmines [__] this
dude
let's go back and get more oh my god
i felt bad for him man when i was a kid
my godmother's husband raul
we had three buildings
i love that name rahul was a bad
[__] he was a human dude i love
rahul raul was married to bever my
godmother
and
i would go up there and spend the
weekend with them
yeah
and i would
well
i will tell you the story you guys might
believe me you might not
there was three buildings there
it was 148th street broadway
they owned the building on the side
the building next to the hobby store and
then in between like in those days it
was like a i don't know like a paint
store or something they owned that
building yeah
and there was an underground tunnel to
all three buildings
all right to connect all three buildings
plus uh some some people threw garbage
in that chute okay so on a certain day
you had to pull the thing out and the
guy would come down and there was a path
but after a few
weeks of living there i learned all the
[__] paths to that there was a boiler
behind there and supposedly a drug
dealer lived upstairs and threw ten
thousand dollars back there oh so me and
my buddies would get flashlights
treasure boiler and one day we looked
over lee and i saw a rat with eyes as
big as your boat the guys oh my goodness
this thing oh that's what it looked like
to me at the age of 10. yeah i [__]
ran home and i never went back there the
rat prom was so bad back there at night
raul got a wolf dog what like one of
those dogs that was half wolf oh yeah he
would just tear him apart you'd go in
there in the morning and there'd be
[__] rats torn apart the wolf would
have claws on his face
the only person he liked was raul wow he
hated me i mean they would have they had
him on a chain
with bolts in the wall this door was a
[__] a real killer wild and when you
went back there he looked at you and he
started [__] running on the walls he
would salivate from his mouth and [__]
he was red killer they just he lived
downstairs like you know how people have
those sex slaves yeah yeah
this dog was so mean they kept him in
the basement just the dungeon dog he
only took him out at night like he only
saw darkness and he'd have to go out
with like a mask and [__]
[__] hysterical i forgot oh that's
fine
what what the [__] about lowell that was
his name low
lowell lowell lobo
name was lobo
yeah
how long did lobo last like six months
and lobo died like some weird poisoning
some rat had poison
the wrong thing ate the wrath from
africa
they had poisonous fang and [__] he had
a spider on his back or something
no i can't
dead spider
oh my god i can't lie to you i don't
remember how he died yeah i don't
remember how he died i know i'd be
traumatized because they had two dogs
they had lobo then they had lassie oh
and last year
that yeah lassie lived in the house
they fed him [__] treats he was
allowed on the first dirty rat eater
lobos
you could even keep him at night i
remember like sometimes you lock the
door and he'd be bouncing on the [__]
door wow like you think he was going to
knock in and eat you well yeah lassie
would talk [__] you have to think no
we'd separate them because he killed
lassie yeah but last you must be like
haha i'm in here i could tell the couch
it was glassy was a beautiful dog i know
that's all i used to walk we used to
have to walk lasty first
then put lassie in and then he'd have to
go and put a mask on lowball a mask
because they can smell they just knew he
just knew that you had another dog right
before he's like nacho nacho lobo
nacho lobo it was [__] crazy how
tough that dog was just some closing
facts on let there be rock that i found
a couple weeks ago which were really
that'll add to bonn scott's
bon scott wrote a lot of these songs
based on real things
and when there's a song whole lot of
rosie yeah he based on this tasmanian
woman that weighed 266 pounds
that went up to him and told him she had
slept with 29 stars that month
and next thing you know he woke up and
he was pinned against the wall and rosie
had [__] the [__] of him and she was
whispering to him he was number 30. oh
pretty interesting stories online
correct and then the one go down go down
there was a girl named wrote roozy ruby
lips ruby lips that was a groupie and
she sucked everybody's dick oh yeah
cause it's like ruby ruby where you been
so long yeah yeah yeah those boys been
drinking whiskey ever since you've been
gone
[Music]
on that lucky stick the way you do okay
i just love that man
you got the touch
yeah no it's uh
it's really interesting things but the
most
interesting was that on the
one of the guitar solos while they were
taping it the speakers actually went on
fire oh yeah the amp
caught on fire yeah and they were
actually looking at bon bon i'm not
bonding i guess angus looked over
and his brother told him keep playing
don't worry about the [__] amps going
on fire yeah that's like problem child
or something yeah that caught fire
just just phenomenal
real [__] a music that listen man
like i said after brian johnson came out
i caught them a few times yeah i'm not
gonna see him lie to you yeah yeah i
think i caught him three times actually
because the angus was just spectacular
totally it really was just a freaking
nature man yeah from beginning to end
and he i don't know it was like the
weirdest thing i'm very happy i came up
at that time and i got to see the bands
i got to see i don't
i wouldn't want to see ac dc at
coachella no yeah like i was blessed to
see him at the guard with bon scott yeah
and i'm really [__] happy you know
those i'm happy a lot of
a lot of times in those days i would go
to concerts and i didn't know what was
going on yeah that concert i knew
exactly what was going on then you know
they played a couple of
they played this
they played a couple songs from my way
to hell yeah they played sin city in
those days it was they were the opening
act totally they played seven or eight
songs but they closed with not bad boy
boogie but the other one and he had to
be rock and he would jump on his
shoulders oh yeah go through the crowd
yeah and go through the crowd it was
just
uh
again you left those shows and you felt
something well yeah also it was weird to
see bonn back then you know
just he had tattoos and no one had him a
big old parrot you know these giant
tattoos on they were giant like when he
came on you're like what is that guy
like you didn't see that he looked like
an old salty sailor up there with the
cut off levi's vest you know remember
years ago when he died they did a a
story about him in the circus yeah that
i run like 200 times yeah he was like
like you said he was really a circus
freak in those days because
he was 15 years elder yeah to anybody
else in the band at that time but he was
so [__] talented and angus and his
brother was so talented and they came
together at such a great time and those
you know again i talk about pink floyd
and you know i always talk about the
brilliance
because anybody could put a special
together but put four [__] brilliant
i know i couldn't do it i could never
[__] do it i would love to tell you
say hey i can write four specials back
to back the back-to-back
that could be brilliant i don't think
anybody's done it lately i've just been
mouth-watering
you know it's very tough or whatever you
judge
but people in those days like pink floyd
ac dc just the [__] yeah i consider
let there be rock power rage and highway
to hell
three [__] masterpieces i don't know
why yeah masterpieces me too also you
got to think about imagine like let's
say
a band like zeppelin the first one
they're like an acid rock blues band
first and two you know then the third
one they got all the acoustic songs and
stuff you know so
that would be equivalent to like say you
go see louis ck and his first special is
this way but then the second special
it's a prop
a prop and then the third one would be
like all one-liners you know and then
the next one would be all crowd work all
these special would be totally different
it would that like comics don't do that
they have a voice and that's their voice
throughout their career that uh you know
through their eyes but imagine if a
comic did that like this special is
going to be all one-liners i've never
done it i'm going to try it and then the
next one you know uh like todd berry did
that crowd work record and tour that's
cool but i'm saying imagine each record
was completely a different style you
know or your style but like tweaked big
time
it's pretty interesting to think about
you know neil brennan had that special
that was three different it's my
favorite three mics unbelievable
super original you know
yeah man super original so it's it's
pretty cool i mean it seems like there's
a lot of comics now who are doing
different shows like i really like how
bert has the uh calling stick to work
shows yeah
yeah and like doug benson does the 420
shows it's just it's interesting to see
and so are you doing like rock clubs a
lot or like or what are you are you
because it seems like you're doing like
legit clubs a lot more yeah you know
like a lot of people think i should do
rock clubs you know but i've i spent my
life in rock clubs right i enjoy the
comedy club you know what i mean because
they bring you food well no it's not
that it's like people understand we're
in a comedy club this is what it is
sometimes you're in a rock club they're
like all right yeah do that one joke you
know they're like yelling out and stuff
right it's a
stump on your punch lines by accident
you know but you're like oh [__] i was
just gonna deliver that you screamed out
hey sir daisy you know what i mean
yeah a different animal you know i enjoy
the comedy clubs i like the uh
the uh the usually a lot of them are
just set up so cool like that comedy
works this weekend man it's just set up
so amazing i couldn't imagine uh
not you know working in there and doing
a rock club around the corner it would
be a bummer you know right i'm actually
i'm interested to listen to the podcast
you did with the owner because
there's not many individual clubs around
the country anymore or major individuals
yeah they're all chains yeah i get it
yeah yeah you said you were banned from
the uh
comedy works
you know you look in hindsight and you
look what people do and
i
was very honored to start at the comedy
works in denver until this day you saw
the smile on my face yeah
i came from good stock you know i was
living in boulder and
i was scared to go on stage i got locked
up
and one day i went down there and got on
stage and matt
woods was down there and i talked to him
and
i went back and did a few open mics and
it just went on and i left and when i
came back i got really serious
i had a daughter in bold i'm like wow if
i get into the comedy works and i
started getting star spots
everything was cool and dandy and then
one night one thing led to another
and we used to hang out there afterwards
again this is why i tell comics at
certain levels do you think get the [__]
out of it yeah why why can't i party
okay do what you want to do this is why
because i was there after hours
and
the the true story was the the the story
was that there was a girl
she was a stripper she was kind of crazy
real cute i was friends but i knew
bro it was like uh your open mic troop
right it was me and and jeff and jimmy
bailey
and this other dude but the other dude i
didn't know like there was like six of
us in this crew but the one dude dug me
yeah but didn't
but didn't
and we were at the same level me and him
were at the same level and one night
we're at this comedy works and we're all
having a good time
and i see i get a star spot
that means that you're an open michael
you come down wednesday you do six
minutes in front of wendy yep and also
wendy he heard wendy tell me do you want
to go get a drink
i think steve mcgrew was in town we're
gonna go right around the corner to the
mexican place and meet steve mcgrew i
could tell he didn't like that
and about a week later i'm there after
hours on a tuesday and i'm walking up
the steps and the girl's walking down
there she just comes in from dancing
with another [__] right she goes joey
how are you she runs down the steps
and she jumps up and she grabs me i grab
oh my hands land behind her ass yeah she
doesn't say nothing
the next day he called her
and he goes listen he grabbed your ass
last night you should press charges and
[__]
so she got an attorney and called down
there and then i got banned wow
and it was tough for her to call me and
go you're banned for life i had to make
a choice at that time i could either
stay in denver and do the three b clubs
yeah or move it up a little bit so i
went up to seattle and that's how i
hooked up with josh wolfe wow boys
but then i saw her on the whatever tour
oddball i'd walter yeah
i was in denver opening and
she came over to me and she asked me how
i was doing like i'm good how are you
one day and she goes are you mad at me
like not at all
can i talk to you for a second you're
the best the reason i'm at oddball
is because you banned me
yeah she goes what are you talking about
i go listen man
if i would have stayed in denver
i would end up hurting somebody i would
have ended up hurting my my daughter's
mother or the boyfriend and i would have
been doing i would have just been
getting that right now well you could
i go you banned me
and you made me
make a decision
i told you guys that when i was in
in 93 i believed that much
and by 95 i had saw the short damage i
had done
by committing
yeah just
three quarters more into this career and
next you know i was on a hbo locals tour
i was taping this i was held i was
featuring here you know they were
country western bars but i was putting
up money in my pocket yeah so i said
jesus if i commit by this point can you
imagine now an awesome boom set back i
get banned from the a room in town
that's the room you want to play that's
the room that you strive to do 15
minutes and four nights a week right and
at that time i was a little far away
from there but i was on my way i was
getting star spots [__] yeah i was a
week or two away from getting made a
regular
and now i was in the rotation so you
don't get spots all the time yeah but
you get one spot a week for seven
minutes and one for 15 minutes
when she told me she took that from me
i had nothing going on in boulder yeah
i was just gonna [__] get into my i
was just gonna get into worse trouble
than i was already in
and i made a decision i said [__] it let
me uh go to seattle and i gunned it out
up there and i ended up here and it's
incredible but once i thanked her for
that yeah
i worked the improv and i did okay
numbers
and my agent goes if you did that at the
improv you do a lot better at that
comedy where he said it's amazing it was
like double wow because people didn't
want to go to denver for some reason
they're scared that they they considered
a black club i thought it was a great
club right i'd just rather play at the
works the works is where i came up
it's the first club i got on stage
totally and i'm really surprised how
open they are to that squad yeah they
really give love to that squad so it's
great it's great to be a part of it it's
a great club i love it man i'm happy
that wendy gives you love now do you do
the other club also in the suburbs once
in a while uh is it really rough how
they say no i like it it's great the
problem is uh like wendy said on my
podcast today when you got the number
one room
if this room was the uh the a second
club was in another town you'd be like
that's the number one room in that town
you know what i mean but when you got
the number one room you're gonna compare
it to the other one but they're both
[__] great one's like a mini theater
and the other one's uh you know a cave
downstairs but they're both great
animals i've had some great shows at
that south club man great ones you know
it's just bigger so it's hard for
someone like me to fill but i did it
like nine nights with russell peters and
it was smoking
you know
i'm proud of you you're savage you got
your first cd
yeah things are moving forward hopefully
all you need is an agent really and an
attorney and you'll be fine you're right
[__] manager you're right number two
i'm really happy you had this out this
this album
[__] with me for like five or six days
every day i had a focus on one song yeah
like the first day was bad boy boogie
the second day was hell in a bad place
to be
you know and i listened to the guitar
and how dirty it was
and then i read up on it and why george
young and the other guy wanda yeah
wanted to make it sound like that and
it's true what you said they wanted to
compete with
punk but again
where would they see dc be today if
bonds got live
would they be bigger do you think they
would have done what they did well he'd
be old as [__] yeah i mean because he
was so much older so was brian [__]
johnson why'd they get rid of him what
was the inside scoop man i don't know
but he you know they said it was his
ears but you know
his ears his ears yeah he was going deaf
or whatever and i just
i just still don't believe that i still
don't believe that i mean i'm sure he
had a little ear problem he said he was
going to take at least going
do you think it's an definitely job what
do you think it is no i think it was he
agree here's what i personally think i
think he agreed to do this last record
and he said i'll do this record and then
we'll do the tour
and uh that should be probably it for us
because you know we're pretty [__]
old and i think
they did the tour in the record then
angus went hey i'm only 62. i'm gonna
keep going
and then just bloop you're out you know
what i mean i that's what i think how
old is brian johnson
i think he's like what what is he like
uh 68 i'm almost positive he's 68.
you know let's look that up that's
impressive and scary at the same time
yeah right because but they can only do
those stadium shows twice a week yeah
that would that will break a man what do
you got there
68 i'm not trying to hold on
yeah 47 so how was that 1947 should say
it right there on the right his age
69 69
yeah your bones start to crack yeah yeah
yeah but you know he doesn't drink
anymore does he i think he drinks yeah
he just doesn't uh we could get crazy
but yeah i think he likes those pints i
always say i'm talking about pints but i
saw him in this last tour twice and uh
no three times and he was [__]
phenomenal so i was like whoa this is
the best i've seen him in 25 years i i
was so blown away like i was like how
the [__] does this guy sound this good
this year you know him and uh axel both
sounded killer out on tour i'm like this
is crazy so i was floored when i heard
he had problems because i was like wow
this guy's killing it even you gotta
remember you've been doing comedy how
long now seven years okay i've been
doing it 26 years
and you learn the tricks later on yeah
yeah you know you watch him on stage
he's as professional as can be yep but
you figure he's been playing
big time rooms since 1980. is that crazy
since july 20 july 31st
of 1981 his career started yeah when
they first took back and black on tour
yeah
what is that that's 20 years there
that's 37 years of touring unbelievable
he has to be just good
and just i don't know how to describe it
yeah i don't know if the musicians have
like a
just a little secret it's just ninja you
know yeah put this on a little louder
lower the light here yeah and i sing
this do this i'm going to do a trick
yeah i'm going to turn it here
again
[__]
you know what i mean yeah he gets away
with it so that's that's the other side
of professionalism yeah that you figure
out different rooms you figure out
different tricks yep and that's what
putting the [__] dime in that's not
from
listen when you go to scotland and play
like this they went around the [__]
world you got to survive uh so yeah
figure out how to survive yeah that's
those guys have stories for [__] days
so where you at you're with me in june
yeah at the brilliant improv yeah i
can't wait and then i'm doing a rock on
the range of you there i'll be on the
sunday day
and then uh do i have anything else come
oh i'm gonna be with burr in july
uh two dates at uh grand rapids
um july 14th and 15th that's all i got
pretty much oh no one what run here june
14th through the 18th house of comedy
minnesota oh [__] yeah headlines that's
my spot that's a good [__] spot i've
never done it i'm looking forward to
and grand rapids is sensational oh yeah
that's the home of the world champion
what's his name
graham he's fighting conor mcgregor
um
mayweather mayweather
mayweather
[__] up lisa
dude thank you for having me what's for
dinner tonight bongo
what's up what's what are you making
bluebonnet what are you making blue
angel
whatever i don't know whatever i get
when i get home i'll probably just pass
out
you're not passing out tonight though
you're eating [__] oh no i had a
blueberry so what did i have blueberry
24.25 listen who counts the blueberry
you burned that off when at the gym
today
you you did the elliptical thing right
right how many calories did you burn the
elliptical i don't know i don't put it
in the thing 300.
i don't put it in the um he's gone now
he's just mumbling now
no i don't put my i don't
log into the thing you don't want to
know your cat you just sit there and
without them no no sit down you don't
you just log there without the thing
i just go for an hour
you don't do no [__] hour [__]
no no i i my spies are there they tell
me
once put a towel on my neck no that was
you he took a picture and said a little
bit to me did you owe me this picture i
erase everything you know me i don't
want no comments
nothing
you don't know how to erase
i don't know collateral you should
you go there for 20 minutes [__]
what you doing now who you [__] i
don't do it
he goes over he talks to paul he hangs
on the thing talking to him
she goes at six in the morning what are
you talking about
i've been jimming it up man i could tell
you're a yolk [__] no sugar
still [__] one year uh two days ago
so one year what's the breakfast at no
sugar man's house
uh i usually wake up and i have a
protein shake and then i eat some what's
in this protein it's a vega one so it's
all mixed up vegan pro
protein shake it's a company vegan one i
love it and then i'll eat fruit like
strawberries and um
and blueberries and then some uh you
know a little bit of a small little bit
of oatmeal
uh some steel cut that's my breakfast
and then lunch
some salmon with brown rice or um some
chicken and black beans and brown rice
uh
something like that and then dinner some
kind of quinoa you know
yeah that way you flew back
quinoa every time a person says yeah
yeah it's a stab through my heart
i get three i lose three minutes in time
right now i said quinoa sounds like a
martial art right it's like if you watch
the ufc it'd be like judo kung fu and
quinoa i know what [__] quinoa sounds
like it just don't sound good
it doesn't sound like something i like
to eat i just saw it once i know what
anything it's [__] good dude you
might as well give me host couscous and
shoot me in the [__] head backwards
[__]
so it's almost cuz it's just rice
quinoa is great couscous is just right
i can't wait till they show a picture of
you one day
with a bag over your head over there
nicest bill
machine gun to your [__] head eating
couscous
i can't wait [__] you'll be
thinking of me you'll never eat couscous
together get out of here i love it
i'm off to the store dude all right
[__] this show is brought to you
by on it explain it to me joey break it
down for a [__] here it is you
want to get healthy you want to get good
products and you want to get good
vitamins in you
you want the good stuff on it's where
it's at whether it's the alpha brain
whether it's the shroom tech sport
whether it's the hemp forest protein
whatever whatever that you need
on it we'll have it there supplement
wise
they have greens they have mixed greens
a cherry flavored they have a recovery
drink
coconut water recovery drink that's
sensational go to honey.com right now
and take a look at the whole fine line
of supplements if you go with alpha
brain 100 money back guarantee you can't
beat that with a stick you understand me
plus they got kettlebells they got the
steel bats they got the steel cage balls
listen
it's one stop shop and go to honda.com
right now look at the great selection
they have whether it's supplement wise
or workout gear and if you like
something
go to check out and press in church
c-h-u-r-c-h we're gonna give you 10
percent off you understand me number two
listen
[Music]
mother's day is coming
nobody nobody wants to have a stinky ass
you look at your mother's ass when you
go to like restaurants
when she gets up you look at your
mother's ass and you know jesus [__]
christ
what does that
cave of death
smell like nobody here am i the only
crazy one here well listen stop the
suspicions
give your mother a portable potato right
now no vegetables why i live there in
doubt it does my grandpa listen i know
your grandmother's [__] smells if
she's over 70 that's got rotten ass give
her a portable day for mother's day if
you go right now
to hellotushy.com right now they got
portable bidets why joey why would i
have a portable day why because you
don't want to have [__] right you
don't want to have hemorrhoids you don't
want to have strange things lurking in
your [__] it all starts with [__]
health and cleanliness what is it what
do they say jesus
cleanliness is next to jesus
godliness you understand me plus you're
helping the environment because if you
use a portable bidet
there's no trees there's no paper
involved they have a little towel right
next to you take it out and you dry your
little muffler you take one hand you get
like a plastic sack you put like that
portable soap in your muffin little
shampoo and you let that little water
hit in there and you take it out and
then you dry your muffin you could do
that all day long you know what i'm
saying in that stink here's the recipe
ladies
if the guy goes went down on you on the
second date and he's never gone down
again the last nine years it's not that
he don't love you it's maybe that skunk
needs some [__]
water you understand me that's where the
portable bidet comes in in mid-afternoon
ladies that onion gets hot in the middle
of the day listen we're not insulting
you but in the middle right by the
noodle where the hairs are right there
right there right there it smells like
[__] what's that thing that was pico
de gallo and i love it don't get me
wrong you know me i'm a [__] animal
anyway
if you don't want that go to
hellotushy.com right now take a look at
the great line of photo of the days
number two 60 day money back guarantee
solid company
solid performance i get nothing but
great reviews about them
and uh it is what it is mother's day is
coming father's day is coming happy
easter's coming so do me a favor right
now go to hellotushy.com and press in
church bam
and get 10 percent off all right hello
tushie on it i love you as both lisa i
love you don't forget wise guys
salt lake city friday saturday cinco de
mayo
mexicans invade [__] salt lake
city
number two next week
milwaukee turner hall friday night few
tickets left don't call don't hit me up
on twitter joey we got no tickets i told
you get the [__] tickets now but you
wanted to play [__] uh possum anyway
i love you guys thank you very much for
listening thank you for the support
thank you for being there for us
[__] lisa throw him a kiss
[__]
there you go we love you stay black i'll
see you guys at wise guys this weekend
thank you for listening
so
time
family
so
time
times
children
you